so to continue our conversation of
really a number of different issues
number one what will Democrats in the
house do now that they've taken over
control of the House of Representatives
number two in what other ways will this
kind of circle of criminality or storm
cloud of criminality drench Donald Trump
with more rain in all of these different
ways there has been the question of what
is going to happen with the House
Intelligence Committee investigation
from the Republican era which ended
number one of course run by Devin Nunez
who was running to trump to tell him
what they were working on and number two
ended prematurely before even all of the
relevant witnesses had been interviewed
as far as what Democrats on that
committee told us what is going to
happen in that committee with regard to
investigating Donald Trump you'll
remember that on Tuesday night at his
one-week delayed State of the Union
address Donald Trump called for an end
to investigations into him well they're
not ending and in fact the opposite is
happening there are new investigation
starting into Donald Trump including by
the House Intelligence Committee we've
heard from the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee Adam Schiff that
a very very significant new
investigation is starting into Donald
Trump's finances and into foreign
influence on Donald Trump now if you're
hearing that in saying another Russia
probe it seems that there's so much more
to look into beyond just the Russia
Trump stuff and you would be absolutely
and completely correct this is a much
broader investigation because we've
learned that the foreign influence on
Trump is not just Russia but Saudi
Arabia is increasingly a point of
interest there are other countries that
are points of interest because we've
learned that Donald Trump's financial
crimes may go well beyond just money
laundering for Russian oligarchs through
New York City real estate there's so
much more to look into that the new
House Intelligence investigation
Intelligence Committee investigation is
going to look into anything that is
related to possible financial wrongdoing
by Donald Trump
and anything else that could be
influencing the way that Donald Trump
makes decisions as president of the
United States this could be Russians
Saudis anybody else and it's not just
going to be the House Intelligence
Committee this is an investigation that
is so massive that it is going to
include other committees as well so the
good news here is that is is that if the
Moller investigation were to end
tomorrow with no more indictments it's
still not the end now I don't think that
that's likely Mollie McHugh who we just
spoke to doesn't think that that's
particularly likely but even if Matthew
Whitaker somehow came up with a way to
end the Muller probe tomorrow or
whatever else took place that ended it
it still is not going to be the end
because the House Intelligence Committee
is just getting started
Donald Trump was asked about this new
probe he didn't really say anything
about it other than attacking Adam
Schiff he said Adam Schiff who runs the
house Intel committee now said quote is
a political hack trying to build a name
for himself interpret that however you
want I was thinking how a Trump ran on
this talking point of draining the swamp
there is a way that Trump may actually
succeed in draining the Swart the swamp
which he promised to do it would be
having so many people around him that
are part of the swamp that committed
criminal acts that they end up resigning
in shame or in prison because of the
investigations that have been triggered
by the Trump presidency that's the only
way that Trump is actually going to
drain the swamp and of an interesting
question for me is whether Devin Nunez
could be caught up in all of this you'll
remember he was the previous chairman of
the House Intelligence Committee which
of course was transparently bogus to
begin with Nunez had been on Trump's
transition team and then he was put in
charge of the House Committee that was
investigating wrongdoing by Donald Trump
so we knew from the beginning that that
was not a an investigation that was
going to come up with anything
substantive and indeed it ended before
all relevant witnesses could even be
interviewed he could potentially be
pulled into this investigation at this
point
and Trump's
steak in retrospect may end up being
having won the election because I don't
think he expected to win from the
beginning I believe that he wanted to
place a sort of respectable second or
third in the Republican primary make
more money from his presence on reality
shows become a more in demand and kind
of well known guy and Trump made the
brutal mistake of overestimating the
intelligence of the voting public he
likely assumed they're never going to
elect me I'm not at risk of actually
becoming president here and then once he
was in too deep his ego his well-known
ego didn't let him drop out of the
election and that's ultimately why we
are in the middle of all of this if you
are someone operating on the fringes of
the law the way Donald Trump has been
doing for so long sort of the last thing
you want is to end up president where
everything that you're doing is going to
end up under under this degree of
scrutiny and if I think forward to
possible documentaries about the Trump
presidency
what happened Tuesday night Trump using
the State of the Union to call for an
end to investigations into him that may
end up being the climax of some really
interesting documentary at some point in
the future